RICK DOBLIN: Yeah,
thank you, thank you.
Well, welcome everybody.
Thank you for coming today.
By way of
introduction, I'll just
say that when I was
18 years old, in 1971,
I started taking LSD.
And I was also a Vietnam
War draft resistor,
I was in the last
year of the lottery,
and I kind of identified myself
as a counterculture, drug-using
criminal.
And so my arc of my life has
been to try to undo that.
I don't really want
to be a criminal,
to be counterculture,
but I do really want
to be a drug user.
So how do we do that
in our current society?
So I've had sort of two
strands of training.
One strand has been in
psychedelic psychotherapy,
and so I've trained
with Dr. Stanislav
Grof, who's the world's
leading LSD researcher.
He's in his 80s now, but he
did work in Prague, and then
at Johns Hopkins in the '50s,
'60s, and '70s, early '70s.
And so I've trained with him
in the holotropic breath work.
And so I wanted
to be a therapist,
a psychedelic
psychotherapist, and that's
where I was headed
for about 16 years.
And then when I
graduated college in '87,
after dropping out for 10 years
from trying to integrate my LSD
experiences, I couldn't really
get into any graduate schools,
because psychedelic
research was shut down.
So I couldn't get
into graduate schools
for a clinical
psychology PhD program,
because whenever I told
them I wanted to do MDMA,
they were like, well, maybe
they're somewhere else
you would be more comfortable.
So then I realized
that the politics was
in the way of the science,
and I felt like, OK,
I really need to shift gears.
I actually was sort of stuck.
I didn't know what to
do, and I smoked some pot
and thought about it from
a different perspective.
And then I thought, yes, OK,
I have a pattern in my life,
I want too much too soon.
And I thought, OK,
here I want the science
but the politics is in the
way, so then I should maybe
study the politics.
So I thought, where
could I do that?
And I had read an interview
with a fellow named
Mark Kleiman, who was
a professor at Harvard
at the Kennedy
School of Government,
and in the interview, he
had mentioned a lawsuit
that I'd been involved
with against the DEA trying
to protect the
therapeutic use of MDMA.
So I contacted him
and I said, would you
be my mentor if I could get in?
And he said yes.
So I've had one strand of
training in public policy,
so I have a Master's and
PhD from the Kennedy School,
and I feel like that's
doing psychotherapy
for sick public policies.
So it's a combination of
individual psychotherapy
and sort of collective
psychotherapy,
and my sort of career
goal-- I'm 62 now,
I'm still not quite
doing what I exactly
want to do-- is to become
a psychedelic therapist
full-time, and we're predicting
that that may be possible
starting around 2021.
So that's by way
of introduction.
This, as you may see,
is the MDMA molecule
in the Google Doodle there.
[LAUGHTER]
One day we hope that
we'll actually see
that on the Google homepage.
[LAUGHTER]
If we succeed, maybe
that will happen.
So I'm just going to briefly
talk about why this matters,
and that's about
mystical experiences
and cultural evolution.
And then I'll talk
about the strategy
to get there, which is
nonprofit MDMA PTSD research.
And then I'll talk about
Burning Man just a bit,
about how we really ease
cultural transformations,
and how that's played
a role, and what we're
trying to do at Burning Man.
So I have previously
given a Google Tech
Talk at the Mountain View
campus six years ago--
bit more than six years ago--
and I watched it in preparation
for this talk.
And it was really
interesting to watch,
because at the time
that I gave that talk,
we had not really gotten the
data from any of our studies.
We were sort of talking
about what I thought
was going to be happening.
And now, six years later,
we're at the conclusion
of an international series
of phase two pilot studies,
and we have a lot of data.
So I will be sharing
some data with you today.
And in preparation
for the talk, I
was trying to think
about, you know,
I am interested in cultural
change, social evolution,
and so I started
thinking, what is Google
doing in the way of long-shot
projects, or moonshot projects?
And so I checked on
the website, and saw
that there's a series kind of
the more wide-ranging moonshot
projects about life extension,
self-driving cars, drones,
for wind turbines and
for transporting goods,
Project Loon on the
internet, Project
Glass for hands-free
reality displays,
and artificial neural networks.
So these were the sort
of moon-shot projects
that I could see that
Google was involved in.
And what I noticed, though,
that these are all obviously
technological projects,
and there is something
that we're all
struggling with, which
is the emotions and
the spirituality,
and sort of the hate at
the heart of many people,
and the fear, and the
anxieties, and that's
what really threatens us.
And how are we going
to really address that?
So I don't think that there
are technological solutions
to that.
And this was sort of highlighted
by Albert Einstein, who
said, "It has become appallingly
obvious that our technology has
exceeded our humanity."
He also said, "The
splitting of the atom
has changed everything
save our mode of thinking,
and thus we drift towards
unparalleled catastrophe.
We shall require a substantially
new manner of thinking
if mankind is to survive."
So what is that new
manner of thinking,
and why is that so important?
There's a little bit of a
clue in the UNESCO charter,
which was developed
shortly after World War II.
"Since wars begin
in the minds of men,
it is in the minds of men
that the defenses of peace
must be constructed."
And what is that?
How do we build
defences of peace?
And there is another clue,
speaking about moonshots,
from Edgar Mitchell.
And so what he said, looking
back on Earth from space, is,
"When we see our
fundamental unity
with the processes of
nature and the functioning
of the universe-- as I so
vividly saw it from the Apollo
spacecraft-- the old ways
of thinking and behaving
will disappear."
There's something about this
unitive cosmic experience
that does have
political implications.
And this for me was really
confirmed in 1983, when
I read this book
by Robert Mueller
called "New Genesis-- Shaping
a Global Spirituality."
And Robert Mueller was the
Assistant Secretary General
of the United Nations.
He was like the
mystic at the UN.
He was there for 40 years.
He's the one that started
the United Nations
University for
Peace in Costa Rica
because Costa Rica
abolished its army.
And what he was
basically saying here
is that there is a context
where we have the United
Nations to mediate
conflicts between countries,
but really what we have is a lot
of religious-based conflicts.
And what he basically said is
that mysticism is the antidote
to fundamentalism, and if we
have this global spirituality,
people will appreciate
other perspectives
rather than be scared of them.
And nowhere in his book, though,
does he mention psychedelics.
So I contacted him and said,
what about psychedelics,
and would you help me bring
back psychedelic research?
And he said yes.
To my utter
astonishment, he wrote
me back a handwritten
note, and that started
a long relationship with him.
And he eventually helped me
in this global-- World Health
Organization, when they were
trying to criminalize MDMA.
And this idea of psychedelics
and mysticism and world peace
was sort of shockingly--
this is just
this recent issue of a
journal called "The Optimist."
The top is "How LSD May Bring
Peace to the Middle East."
And it turns out this is an
interview with Stan Grof,
and he's talking
about a conference
that he wants to organize that
we're talking about working
on together, that he calls
"A Light from Middle East The
Common Roots of the
Abrahamic Traditions,"
Islam, Judaism,
and Christianity.
And what he wants
to do is really
bring, again, the
mystics together,
and help them try to
develop strategies to deal
with the fundamentalists.
And what I really was able
to talk to Robert Mueller
about, and sort of give you
now a little bit of data,
in a sense, about this
psychedelic mysticism,
is from the Good
Friday experiment.
This is the best thing
that Timothy Leary ever
did, in my view.
He was the faculty sponsor
for this at Harvard.
It was in 1962.
And it was a
scientific study trying
to evaluate whether people with
a religious tradition-- these
were Christian
divinity students,
in a religious setting--
whether psilocybin
mushrooms-- extracted
psilocybin--
whether that would be promoting
of a mystical experience.
And so they went into Marsh
Chapel at Boston University,
and they went through
a Good Friday service,
and half got psilocybin
pills and half got placebo.
And this was actually-- they
did it in the downstairs chapel.
That's me there giving
a little homily.
And they had 10 people,
as well, that were
part of the experimental team.
Half of them got the
psilocybin, half of them
got the placebo as well.
And the minister
was Howard Thurman.
So to give you an idea
of how non-controversial
this was in 1962, Howard
Thurman was Martin Luther King's
mentor.
Martin Luther King got a
PhD at Boston University.
He was an incredible,
dynamic preacher,
and he agreed to let
a bunch of people
take psilocybin in
the basement while he
was doing Good Friday services.
And it was piped in, and we
have the original sermons
that he gave.
They're up on our website.
They were saved.
And how do you tell if somebody
has a mystical experience?
So Walter Pahnke
spent a year surveying
the religious literature, and
he developed a questionnaire
of the mystical experience,
and this was extracted
from the different religions.
So he wanted to do it where
even though it was Good Friday,
and it didn't have
anything to do with Jesus,
or any particular
religious tradition.
This was sort of the essence
of the mystical experience.
And the key part was
the sense of unity.
That's what Edgar Mitchell
was talking about as well,
this internal and external,
that it's all together.
We get there from
quantum physics,
in some ways, that a lot
of what we're understanding
is how we are all
intimately connected.
There's this feeling
of this transcendence
of time and space.
There is a sense of sacredness.
There is a sense of
objective reality.
There's a deeply
felt positive mood,
and there's this sense that
it's beyond words, that you
can't really put it into words.
This is like an
MC Escher drawing,
just doesn't make sense.
And then there was
various questions
that operationalized
these definitions,
and then you could get a
numerical score on how deep
was your mystical experience.
And I ended up realizing
in the middle '80s,
when I wanted to do psychedelic
research, when I needed
to do a thesis for
my undergraduate,
is that psychedelic
research was blocked--
and it had been blocked
for almost two decades--
but the real issue with mystical
experiences in the literature
is the fruits test.
It's not how you
describe it, it's
what are the fruits
of the experience?
Are they positive,
are they opening?
And so I realized that I could
go back and ask the people that
were in the study
what they thought
were the long-term
effects on their lives.
And Walter Pahnke, who
had done the experiment,
actually had died in a scuba
diving accident in 1971.
So I'm convinced
that he would have
done this long-term follow-up
if he would have been alive.
So I was able to, through
all sorts of detective work,
find 19-- identify 19
out of the 20 people,
and I interviewed 16 of them.
And one of them
told me this thing,
"We took such an infinitesimal
amount of psilocybin,
and yet it connected
me to infinity."
So I re-administered the same
questionnaires to these people,
and there's a lot
of data, but I just
wanted to show you
that this point here.
60 or above was considered
a full mystical experience.
And so this was
the original data,
and then this one here is my
long-term, 25 years later.
And you can see
the placebo group.
It's almost identical,
even after 25 years.
And this is in the midst of the
Reagan escalation of the drug
war, so if there was
any time, culturally,
for people to
disavow the validity
of their prior
psychedelic experience,
this would have been it.
And yet they affirmed it.
And what, more importantly,
they said to me--
and this was through all
of these interviews--
that the mystical experience
had political implications,
and it fundamentally
increased their tolerance
of other religions, it
deepened their equanimity
in the face of life crises,
it promoted greater solidarity
and identification with foreign
peoples, minorities, women--
this was all men in this
experiment-- and nature,
and it reduced
their fear of death.
So we're starting
to see that there
is some kind of long-term effect
from this mystical experience.
The modern research that is
taking place with psilocybin
here in New York at
NYU, at Johns Hopkins,
and also at UCLA, has
been going on for a while.
And what Roland
Griffiths has done
is he's sort of updated the Good
Friday experiment, in a sense.
What he's done is he's
taken people who are not
religious professionals,
and he has taken them
in a setting that is
not a religious setting,
in a clinical setting,
given them psilocybin,
and find that they still
have mystical experiences.
And many of them rank them as
the top five most important
experiences of their life.
They also have done these
personality tests with people,
and personality is
considered to be pretty fixed
once you're an adult, and
what they found surprised
them, is that there
was long-term changes
in people's
personalities related
to the mystical experience.
And that was in the
dimension of openness.
And this is-- Katherine MacLean
has written this paper she
was part of their team.
"Mystical experiences occasioned
by the hallucinogen psilocybin
lead to increases
in the personality
domain of openness."
And again, this is
starting to be a little bit
more modern evidence, again,
about how social change could
be impacted by these
psychedelic-induced mystical
experiences.
They use the NEO
Personality Inventory.
There's five
domains, six facets,
but the openness to
experience is the one
that was really changed.
I think when you talk about
rigidity and fundamentalism,
people are not open
to new experiences,
they're not open to new ideas.
And that's what she
found was changed.
And her paper said
this. "Consistent
with participant claims
of hallucinogen-occasioned
increases in aesthetic
appreciation, imagination,
creativity, we found significant
increases in Openness following
a high-dose psilocybin session.
And what I've written
down below there
is that we have found similar
changes in openness on the NEO
with our MDMA research with
post-traumatic stress disorder
patients, and we're
working on getting
those papers published as well.
So there does seem to
be something going on.
And it's also, when we talk
about spirituality, we all
should have the right to
explore our own consciousness,
to explore our connection
to the religion,
and to our meaning
of the universe.
It's not just idle curiosity,
it's a fundamental human right.
And this was an article
from the MAPS Bulletin.
This is the first
articulation by a donor,
by a foundation, that their
support of our research
was part of their
human rights mission.
This is the Pritzker, Nick
and Susan Pritzker Family
Foundation, from the family
that own the Hyatt hotels.
And their foundation
is focused-- The Libra
Foundation-- on human rights.
And so, there is
this sense that this
is a broader issue
as well, in terms
of our own personal freedoms.
And how do we get there though?
Because we're stuck
with prohibition,
at least at the moment.
Now, we see that
prohibition is eroding.
It's a great thing
to see the rise
of the interest in
marijuana legalization
and the concerns about
over-incarceration.
And here is the
strategy that explains
why trying to do psychedelic
psychotherapy research
is really part of changing
cultural attitudes.
This is a chart showing the
attitudes of American voters
over the last 40 plus years on
the legalization of marijuana.
And what it shows is
that, starting in 1970,
it's down around 12%.
And just a few years
ago, it crossed
the line and more
than 50% of the public
is in favor of legalization.
But what's most interesting
to me about this
is this long period
here from around '76
to around '96 here-- almost
20 years-- where it's flat.
Nothing's going on.
And somehow, things
start changing again.
And they start moving up.
And what is it that happens
around 1996 that starts
to change people's attitudes?
Medical marijuana.
California and Arizona passed
medical marijuana laws in 1996.
And polling has been
done-- exit polling,
after people have voted
on marijuana initiatives
in different states.
And what we've found is that
the single most important factor
about whether
somebody is in favor
of the legalization
of marijuana is not
if they use
marijuana themselves.
You would think
that marijuana users
don't want to be criminals.
But it's if they know a medical
marijuana patient personally.
That changes their attitudes.
Because there's so
much propaganda.
People don't know
what to believe.
Even people that
smoke pot sometimes
think it's not good
to make it legal.
But this is the theory
of social change
here, that the medicalization
changes attitudes,
brings a more accurate
risk-benefit analysis
to people.
They know people
who have benefited.
And then, they start
changing their attitudes
towards legalization.
So that has led us now to this
idea of, how do we do this?
And we're thinking about, how
do we integrate psychedelics
into our culture?
And I want to point
out that it's not new.
If we go to the beginnings
of Western culture
with the Greeks, the
longest running mystery
ceremonies that we're
aware of, for 2,000 years,
was the Eleusinian Mysteries.
And they were wiped out by
the Catholic Church in 396.
And Albert Hoffman,
who invented LSD
and first synthesized
psilocybin,
did some studies with
Greek scholars and others.
And they noticed that, in
the Eleusinian Mysteries,
they drink a potion
called kykeon.
And then, they walk a
certain number of hours.
And then, they
have this ceremony.
And they've timed how long
it takes to do the walk
and how long it takes what
they know was in the potion.
And it's at the
peak of the trip,
you're at this place
for the ceremony.
So that's from our
Western culture.
And when we think
about the Greeks
and we think about the people
that started our culture-- so
Plato, Aristotle, Pythagoras,
Cicero, Sophocles,
they all participated in
these mystery ceremonies.
So even though it's
1,600 plus years ago,
it's not something new that
we're trying to bring back.
And there is a lot of-- I
can understand a bit how
religion and superstition has
a lot of misinformation in it.
And so we did have
to separate a bit,
so the rational mind could move
ahead unfettered by all this.
But now, we need to
bring it together again.
So I happened to be at Google in
December out in Mountain View.
And I was walking actually.
One of our donors is there.
And before I left, I
wanted to get some Google
Frisbees for my kids.
And we were walking
to the Google store.
And we passed this
sign on the campus.
And I did a double take.
You can't see what
I was looking at.
But here, I noticed
that there was a Google
Department of World Peace.
And it was room 2021.
And for us, that's meaningful.
So the ultimate moonshot,
obviously, is world peace.
I'm really glad to see
that Google is involved.
It turns out, as
far as we can tell--
and I'm sort of embarrassed
to say that I was in a hurry.
So I didn't go to
see if there was
that room that actually exists.
But the MAPS donor is
going to check it out.
But I've searched
on the internet.
It seems to be a joke.
But I hope it's not.
And I did think that the
2021 room was incredible.
Because our drug
development plan
shows that MDMA will
be approved by the FDA,
if all goes to plan, in 2021.
So maybe there is some secret
Google plan to support MAPS
and to make psychedelics
into legal medicines.
And it makes sense.
Because this is an article
from the "Washington Post."
They talked about MDMA
as the peace drug.
So OK, that fits with the
Department of World Peace.
And here we are in the Pentagon.
So actually, this is Dr. Richard
Rockefeller, Michael Mithoefer,
our lead psychiatrist.
And you're not supposed
to take pictures.
So I did it pretty quickly.
But we were speaking with
senior members of the Navy--
the Navy Surgeon General,
Assistant Secretary
of the Navy, and
others-- about trying
to do MDMA research
with Marines with PTSD.
Eventually, they decided they
would be much more comfortable
if we started working
with veterans instead
of active-duty soldiers.
But we are working on
the MDMA peace plan.
And this is what we're
hoping will happen in 2021,
that we'll be able to sell--
GMP means Good Manufacturing
Practices-- medical-grade MDMA.
We'll have programs
to train therapists.
And also, we're going to have a
network of psychedelic therapy
clinics.
So one day, you'll be
able to go to Google Maps
and press, where is the
nearest psychedelic clinic?
And you'll get--
And we anticipate that,
actually, the model here
is the hospice movement.
In 1974 was the first hospice.
30 years later, there was 3,500
of them, all over America.
So it takes 20, 30 years for
new cultural things to roll out.
But we anticipate
that there will
be these psychedelic centers.
And they will
eventually be places
where people go to
therapy but, also,
can go to have these
personal growth experiences.
So OK, how do we now
medicalize psychedelics?
And the journey
actually, for me,
began from a political
point of view
in 1984, when the DEA first
tried to criminalize MDMA.
From the middle '70s to the
early '80s, MDMA was legal.
It was used under
the code name Adam.
It was distributed through
underground psychedelic therapy
networks.
Over a half a million doses
were used in that context.
And the government
had no knowledge
that that was going on.
But some of those people
took MDMA, said, wow,
this is a great drug.
More people should have it.
It should be more
widely available.
And we're going to
name it Ecstasy,
and we're going to
sell it in public.
And that was, eventually,
obviously going
to doom the whole thing.
Because it was done in
more public settings,
people knew about it, and
it was the Reagan era.
So in the summer of '84, the
DEA moved to criminalize.
And we had been
preparing for years ahead
in anticipation of this.
And we had great DC law firms
working pro bono for us.
So I walked to the
DEA headquarters.
So that's the picture
of me spying on the DEA,
right before I
walked in the door
to totally surprise
them with this petition,
which they eventually granted.
And we did get a DEA
administrative law judge
lawsuit.
We won the case.
The judge said, MDMA should
be therapeutically available
still.
And the head of the DEA
administrator rejected it.
We sued him in
the appeals court.
We won a couple times.
Eventually, the DEA
lawyers figured out
how to reject our application
and still satisfy the courts.
And then, it felt
to me like there's
no way else but through
medicine, through the FDA.
So in '86 is when
I started MAPS.
And our strategy-- I call
it the Aikido strategy.
Because what you're
doing is you're
using the momentum of your
opponent against them.
You're not actually even
directly hurting them.
And in this case,
what we're using
is the fact that
MDMA, LSD, marijuana,
these are all demonized drugs.
And governments
all over the world
have spent hundreds of millions
of dollars trying to show
what's bad with these drugs.
Now, some of their
interpretations
are a little bit skewed.
But the point is that
there is an enormous amount
of information on this drug.
If you go to Medline and
you put in MDMA or Ecstasy,
there's over 5,100
papers on MDMA or Ecstasy
at a estimated cost
of over $300 million.
And the risks are
well-characterized.
We know about the
mechanisms of action.
And over 1,100 people
have been given
MDMA in clinical settings.
Only about 150 by us, a
little bit less than that.
And the rest are
by people trying
to understand risks and
mechanisms of action,
things like that, that
we've not had to pay for.
But there's a lot of
safety information.
And now, is this
really so demonized?
Last Sunday, in the
"New York Times,"
the "Sunday Review"
section, the cover article
was about "A Drug to Cure Fear."
And this was the
illustration that they
used in the "New York Times."
And it was about propranolol,
which is a beta blocker.
It reduces anxiety.
And they tried to have
people talk a little bit
about their trauma, while under
the influence of propranolol
and see if that would
help them get over--
every time they remember
it again-- being fearful.
And this article said, "A
2015 review of PTSD treatment
studies published in
'Biological Psychology'
found that propranolol
administered
with six brief
trauma reactivation
sessions significantly
improved PTSD symptoms
compared with a placebo."
So they're starting
to show evidence
of this drug-assisted
psychotherapy.
But MDMA is likely to work a
lot better than propranolol
in these models.
And at the end of the
article, Richard Friedman--
who's here in New York-- the
final paragraph of the article
was, "I see nothing
wrong with doing
all we can to rid ourselves
of pathological anxiety,
including using drugs to
alter our painful memories."
He's not actually a fan of MDMA.
So he would probably
be upset if he
saw that I was using him
to endorse MDMA research.
But the principle is this
idea of psychotherapy
combined with a drug is
getting more and more accepted.
And people see that as
potentially helpful.
And the public attitudes
have been changing.
This was about 15 years ago.
This was the first image in the
media of positive connections
to Ecstasy.
This was an Israeli newspaper.
We had a project in Israel.
And this was, like, the
helicopters in the background,
like a soldier in
a blood Red Sea,
holding onto an Ecstasy
pill as a life saver.
So when you see the
images in media,
this really started
saying, wow, this
is the first positive one ever.
More recently, Oprah-- who
to her shame, I would say,
10 years before this, 2001,
she had a show on MDMA.
And she showed doctored,
fake images of MDMA
supposedly causing
holes in the brain.
They just took a SPECT scan.
And they just said,
every place that
has activity below
a certain level,
they'll just show as a hole.
So in 2001, though, "O
Magazine" published an article
about MDMA.
This was the illustration
that they used.
And it was, Can a single
pill heal your pain?
So this is, of course,
propaganda on the other side.
But we'll accept it.
[LAUGHTER]
And this, more recently,
was in October.
This is the "Canadian
Medical Association Journal."
This is all about
psychedelic drugs.
And again, you're
starting to see,
we've had incredibly good
publicity over the last 10,
15 years as culture is ready
to look at psychedelics again.
And so, how do we do it?
The first thing
that we need to do
is we need to get
medical-grade MDMA.
I had MDMA manufactured in
1985 by Dave Nichols at Purdue
University for our research.
It was $4,000 for
one kilogram of MDMA.
MDMA is an incredibly
stable molecule.
So 31 years later now, we're
using that exact same MDMA
in our research.
And he had a good yield.
He had more than a kilogram.
We have 960 grams left.
But it's not medical-grade.
It's not something that
we can use in Phase 3.
So we did a international search
for pharmaceutical companies.
And we made a deal
with this Shasun.
They're making us one kilogram
of medical-grade MDMA.
To make it and put it
into capsules is $400,000.
And it's not any better or
purer than what we already have.
It's just more documentation,
more paperwork,
more standardization.
So this is the first step.
And the production-- I just
got an e-mail the other day
that they've finally
got permission
from the home office in
England to buy the precursors.
So we're on the road
to having the world's
supply of medical-grade MDMA.
AUDIENCE: Where is all the
MDMA on the street coming from?
RICK DOBLIN: Well--
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question.
RICK DOBLIN: So the question
is, where's all the MDMA
on the street coming from?
Well, if I knew, I
wouldn't tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's coming from
underground chemists.
Some of them are really
interested in purity.
And others are just
interested in money.
So there's Erowid, which is
a website about psychedelics.
We started a
project-- actually, it
was the number 10 employee
of Microsoft-- Bob Wallace
said, a lot of this MDMA that's
being sold as Ecstasy is not
really MDMA.
So we have an Ecstasy
pill-testing program.
He donated over $100,000.
And it turns out that more than
half of the Ecstasy or Molly
doesn't have any
MDMA in it at all.
So you have to be
really wary of it.
But there are people that supply
underground therapy networks.
And so, there is some pure
stuff out there as well.
But it's all
underground chemists.
The same place that LSD
comes from and all of that.
So we're getting that.
And then, just to give you
a little bit of a sense.
What is our therapy method?
It's not one-dose miracle-cure.
The therapy method is basically
a 3 and 1/2 month process.
And it's weekly
non-drug psychotherapy.
Those are the vertical lines.
And the triangles are
the MDMA sessions.
So one month apart, there is
three of these MDMA sessions
in a 3 and 1/2 month process.
So a lot of emphasis on
preparation, on integration.
And in our current
studies, we break the blind
after the second session.
And then, those people
that had the placebo
could go through it
again as open label.
Meaning, they know
they're getting MDMA.
So it's both comparing people
against a controlled group.
And then, also people
are their own controls,
once we give them MDMA.
So that's the basic experiment.
And we have developed
a treatment manual
to try to standardize, what
is our therapeutic approach?
For research,
everything that you can,
you need to standardize.
This is based on a non-directive
approach from LSD research.
We are now getting ready to
negotiate with FDA and what's
called the End-of-Phase 2
meeting, where you summarize
all of your data, and
you submit the data,
and you ask for permission
to go to Phase 3.
Phase 3 is what really counts
to make a drug into a medicine.
Phase 2 are these small,
pilot, exploratory studies.
So we have 105 people
so far with PTSD
that have been in our studies.
And we have data that I'll show
you from around 95 of them.
We're wrapping up
all of these studies.
We hope, in April,
to submit to FDA.
And the first thing
that FDA wants to know
is about the safety.
So in the scientific
literature, the concern
is that Ecstasy users might
have reduced cognitive functions
in certain ways.
And some studies
have shown that.
But it's really hard to
piece apart Ecstasy users.
They've done all
these other drugs.
They don't sleep.
There's all sorts of things.
So is it really from MDMA?
So we've done
neurocognitive studies
with people in our
clinical contexts.
And we've combined two of the
different studies together.
You need to have two
independent studies
to satisfy the FDA that it's
not just a fluke from one study.
And so, the blue lines
are before the experiment
at baseline.
And then, the red line is after.
So what you can
see is that there
is no change in
neurocognitive functioning,
either from the active
doses or the placebo
or the comparator,
which is low doses.
So we have a very
good safety profile,
in terms of
neurocognitive function.
This is, now, body temperature.
You may have heard about
how people go to raves,
they dance all night,
they overeat and die.
And that does
happen occasionally.
It's called hyperthermia.
And so, we monitor
everybody's temperature.
And so, people's temperature
tends to go up during the day.
And we give MDMA at
10:00 in the morning.
And by 6:00 at night, it's
an eight-hour session.
Then, people can rest.
And the therapists leave.
And so, this is the temperature.
And it doesn't go
up hardly at all.
There is no risk.
This is the variation of bars
so you can see the range.
But there is no concern
about temperature overheating
in a clinical setting.
This is blood pressure.
MDMA increases blood pressure.
You can see, again here,
that there is minimal rises.
And this is the range.
That's systolic, and
here is diastolic.
Again, that's the range.
So we've got really good
safety data on neurocognitive,
on temperature,
on blood pressure.
And then, what about
psychological effects?
So the kind of adverse effects
that people are reporting
are anxiety, jaw clenching.
And this is displayed
from low dose
to the full dose--
125 milligrams.
So jaw clenching is one of
the big ones, no appetite.
The reason I've highlighted the
ones under the 30 milligram,
is just to show
that muscle tension,
fatigue happened at the
low doses more even,
sometimes, than the high doses.
So none of this is problematic.
There has not been a single
drug-related serious adverse
event in all of these 1,100
people, not just our studies.
So we have conclusively,
in our view--
and we believe the
FDA will agree--
have demonstrated safety.
And they keep giving us
permission to do protocols.
So that's another example.
As do regulators
around the world.
So now, I'm going to switch
to the efficacy data.
It's a little bit, again, dry.
But I just want to
give you a few quotes
emotionally of what people say.
This was a veteran.
"I feared I was losing
in my effort to live.
I went through
three MDMA sessions
and it gave me my life back."
Another one, "I'm 100%
different than what
I was when I started."
And then, this was a woman who
was sexually abused as a child.
And she said, "since I've
been cured of PTSD, I only
suffer from one thing with
PTSD, and that's the survivor's
guilt. I got heled, while I am
surrounded by people who don't
know that they have any hope.
Who, until this medicine is
approved, probably don't."
There are a lot of good
therapies for PTSD.
But there's large
numbers of people
who are chronic
treatment resistant PTSD.
Right now, the
Department of Defense
is giving disability payments
to 600,000 vets for PTSD
at a cost of around $6 billion
a year, which is outrageous.
And that's going to continue.
So when we think about the
cost of war, $6 billion a year.
That's going up.
These people, a lot
of them are young.
They're going to be living
for another 40, 50 years.
And so, the enormous burden
of PTSD on our society
and on those people
that have it.
So this is a summary chart.
The key point is that we know
about statistical significance.
But with clinical
research, more and more,
people have moved to
looking at effect size.
The FDA really looks
at effect size.
Because you can have
statistically significant
results, even if you have
clinically marginally
significant effects.
So effect size is about the
magnitude of the effect.
And we have got the
good fortune of the FDA
director of psychiatry products,
who's recently retired.
And he reviewed our protocols
for the last 15 years.
And he says, he likes the
way we're doing things.
So he's now acting
as our consultant.
So we now have hired.
Basically, MAPS is a nonprofit
pharmaceutical company,
trying to develop
psychedelics into medicines.
So that's how I think
of what we're doing.
We're primarily doing FDA
drug development research.
And what he said is that the
drugs that the FDA approves,
they almost never cure
anything in psychiatry.
They're all palliative
for symptoms.
And they almost all have
a very small effect size
of around 0.3.
And so, what we have
is a large effect size.
And these are their effects.
They're over 1.
So other than just
one small study, where
some of the placebo
people actually did better
than the full-dose MDMA people,
we have large effect sizes.
And then, when you combine it
all, this is our combined data.
We've just got these
the last few days.
So what it just shows
is the baseline,
then at the primary
endpoint, which is
the end of the blinded portion.
And then, the people
at the top in the blue,
which are in the
placebo group, we
give them the chance
to get MDMA afterwards.
So the 12-month follow-up
is after everybody
has gotten MDMA.
And you can see
that they all end up
pretty much the same place.
And that there's a
significant difference, when
we look at the primary
outcome blinded portion of it,
and a large effect size.
This is just to show you another
way of looking at the data.
The comparator doses-- we
tried, for double-blind,
to use low dose MDMA
compared with full dose.
And so, there is a little bit
of a decrease in their scores.
It's called the CAPS scores,
the Clinician Administered PTSD
Scale.
That's the measure developed by
the VA, used by FDA to evaluate
the severity of PTSD.
And the active doses
are, again, much larger.
So we believe that, based
on this data-- and this
is putting it all
together from the baseline
to the 12-month follow-up.
The point is that the
benefits last over time.
They don't just fade away.
It's not just the
psychedelic afterglow
and, then, it fades
as reality comes back.
There's something
fundamentally changed.
And that's what's
really exciting to us.
And it's not after daily MDMA.
It's only after a few doses.
Some people do relapse.
This is a slide of
just three people.
The FDA gave us permission to
give one more session of MDMA
to people that had their
PTSD symptoms come back
after the year follow-up.
And of these three people, when
we gave them an additional MDMA
session, their
symptoms all went down.
The red line there is
moderate to severe PTSD.
That's what they had to be
above to be in our study.
They're all below that.
And then, at the one-year
follow-up, two of them
were still lower at that.
But one had relapsed.
So I don't want to give the
wrong impression that you
give MDMA to somebody,
it fixes them
for the rest of their life.
People who have
PTSD have usually
had a history of trauma.
They're more vulnerable
to more life shocks.
But it does last.
And the averages that
I've showed you before
include the people
that relapsed.
This was now the study in vets.
The point here I want to
make is that we were shocked,
in that we were doing 30
milligrams, 75 milligrams, 125
milligrams.
And I thought that there would
be a dose response curve.
But it turned out that the
red is the 75 milligrams.
The medium dose actually did
better than the full dose.
And when those of us--
underground therapists
tend to work at the
125 milligrams dose.
This was a real surprise.
And we also are starting to
understand research and memory
reconsolidation.
And so, this helps
us understand that.
That when you have a memory
and you bring it back,
it's not like a book
and you look at it
and you put the
book on the shelf.
You sort have to
reprint the book.
You reconsolidate the memory.
And so, if you have
a traumatic memory
and it's associated
with fear, if you're
recalling the memory
when you're feeling safe,
when you reconsolidate
the memory,
you have memory for the
autobiographical details.
But the emotional
tone is now overlaid
by that feeling of safety.
And at the 75 milligrams,
people stay more grounded.
They stay more in
their biography.
At the 125, people have
more spiritual feelings.
They have more body feelings
that are pleasurable.
But they're a little bit
away from their trauma.
So this is helping
us to understand.
And now, the Rockefeller
family-- Richard Rockefeller
was a major ally.
He died in a plane crash.
To honor Richard, his
family has funded research
at Rockefeller University
with animal models,
looking at MDMA and
memory reconsolidation.
So we're starting
to understand that.
This is to show-- this
is the depression data.
So a lot of people
that have PTSD also
have co-morbid depression.
And depression also
goes down as well.
And this is, now, a key
point-- difference between MDMA
and psychedelic research
with classic psychedelics.
What has found from
the '50s and '60s
and is also the case with
the current research--
with psilocybin
and cancer patients
or with psilocybin and
alcoholics or tobacco addicts--
the depth of the
mystical experience
is correlated with
therapeutic outcome,
the loss of the fear of death,
the sense of connection.
We do the same
questionnaire with MDMA.
And so this shows that
the mystical experience
is pretty good, pretty
strong, even with people
who get MDMA, which
is not known for being
as spiritual in some ways
as the classic psychedelics.
And so, we show that
the comparator doses
have relatively low scores
on the mystical experience
questionnaire.
The active doses
are much fuller.
But this is the key
point here, which
is this is a chart
showing the relationship
between the drop in CAPS scores
and the mystical experience.
And it's flat.
What we're showing is
there is no correlation
between mystical experience
here and therapeutic outcome.
That's the
fundamental difference
between what we're doing
in the psilocybin research.
And that also explains that we
have a non-directive approach.
We're not trying to help people
have a mystical experience.
We're trying to just help them
emerge whatever is coming up
and, particularly,
focusing on peacefully
looking at their trauma.
So what we've learned is, there
is safety in clinical settings,
the large effect size, the
cause of the PTSD is irrelevant.
We've worked with veterans,
firefighters, police officers,
women survivors of child sexual
abuse, adult rape and assault,
workplace accidents.
The cause of the PTSD
doesn't really matter.
We can enroll anybody.
And that the double-blind--
as you should not
be surprised to learn--
didn't really work.
People can tell if they've
got an inactive placebo--
[LAUGHTER]
--or if they get the MDMA.
But the low doses of MDMA had
an anti-therapeutic effect.
So that was a big problem.
And what our FDA
consultant has said
is that we can't really solve
the double-blind problem
and that we'll just
have to compare
with an inactive placebo.
So what we're
proposing is Phase 3
will be inactive
placebo with therapy.
So it's basically therapy
with an inactive placebo
versus therapy with MDMA.
That's going to
be our comparison.
We'll use three MDMA sessions
with 12 non-drug sessions.
We'll give everybody the
75 milligram dose first.
And then, on their second
and third sessions,
we'll have a discussion between
the therapists and patients.
Do they want to have the same?
Or do they want to
have it stronger?
They won't know the doses.
They won't know even if
they've got the placebo or not.
But they'll just say, I want it
the same or I want it stronger.
And that's how we'll do it.
And then, because the
double-blind problem
is an issue, what
means more important
is the independent raters.
So the therapists don't
say, how are you doing?
And you're doing much better.
Because that could be biased.
So we have a group
of [INAUDIBLE]
liability-trained
outcome-measure experts.
And they will do this
all by telemedicine.
And they'll be randomly assigned
to which person they review.
So they won't know,
is this the baseline?
Is this the outcome?
Is this the 12-month follow-up?
And this is what we're going
to be proposing to FDA.
We're anticipating 400
subjects, $22 million.
And I don't know how
many of you might
know a program called HSPICE.
It's used to produce computer
manufacturing computer chips.
The developers of it--
Ashawna Hailey and Kim Hailey.
Ashawna was on our
board of directors.
And after he sold his company,
made a whole bunch of money,
he went into studying
consciousness
and did all sorts of stuff, got
very involved in psychedelics.
He died, left us $5.3
million in his will.
And we're using that
for the Phase 3 studies.
And Dr. Bronner's from-- I don't
know how many of you have read
the label on--
[LAUGHTER]
--Dr. Bronner's--
AUDIENCE: All one.
RICK DOBLIN: Yeah, all one.
Dr. Bronner was traumatized
by the Holocaust,
sort of driven crazy.
But his thing was we all
need to love each other.
We're all together.
We're all one.
And his grandson, David
Bronner, went to Harvard,
is a really smart guy and
has built the business up
with his brother Mike.
And they are very
charitable oriented.
It's a benefit corporation.
David's on our
board of directors.
They've pledged $1 million
a year for five years,
starting next year.
And the reason is
because, this year,
they want to help legalize
marijuana on the 2016
elections.
And one of the
other tech people--
he wanted to stay
anonymous at the moment--
has pledged $1 million
after we agree with FDA.
And I said, why is it that
you want to be anonymous?
And he said, well,
business reasons.
And I said, what would it take
for you to not be anonymous?
He said, if you can
get 1,000 people,
I would come out
with all of them.
So if any of you know people
that are ready to come out,
we're starting to
gather a list of people
who make contributions that
the world would recognize
and, then, who would say, yeah.
Well, psychedelics have
been important in my life.
Now, what I've
learned more recently
is that, once you make a drug
into a medicine-- I thought,
MDMA is in the public domain.
There is no use patents.
We actually hired
patent attorneys
to develop an
anti-patent strategy.
And I'm actually doing that.
I'm on the board of directors
of a company that is genetically
screening marijuana
strains and putting them
in the public domain, so
nobody could patent them.
So there will be hundreds
of marijuana strains
that are genetically
characterized
in the public domain.
But it turns out
that Reagan-- who
I've demonized in my mind in so
many different ways-- in 1984
a law passed.
He signed it.
And what it said was, there
are certain incentives
for developing drugs
that are off-patent.
And what that means is that
you can get data exclusivity.
It means nobody can use
your data for five years
to market it as a generic.
But other people
could do the research
to make the drug
into a medicine.
They could sell it too.
So right now, there's
a possibility that MAPS
and Heffter or
Usona-- which is going
to work on the
psilocybin-- that we'll be
the ones that do the research.
And then, we may
have this period
of five years-- in
Europe, it's 10 years--
where we're the only
ones marketing this drug.
And so, if we make the drug for
$50 and we sell it for $200,
we can use this money to
pay for more research.
So now, the story that
I'm telling donors
is that we have a
sustainability plan,
that, unlike most
non-profits-- like Feeding
the Hungry, there's always
going to be more work to do,
more money you have to raise.
But we have this opportunity
to make MDMA into a medicine
and then not need to ask
donors for as much money,
because we'll be having
some income stream.
At the same time, we don't
want to really monopolize it.
So if anybody does want to
make MDMA into a medicine other
than us, we will help them.
And so we make our
protocols public.
Our data is public.
All of this is trying
to encourage others.
But so far, we haven't seen
anybody step into it yet.
And so we have formed
a benefit corporation.
Selling MDMA and
making money-- it's
not something that you can
keep inside a nonprofit.
It's something that's taxable.
But a lot of people talk about
legalization of marijuana.
And they say, we don't
want big tobacco.
Or we don't want big
alcohol marketing marijuana.
They're going to market to kids.
They're going to do
all sorts of stuff.
So having drugs that have
an abuse liability marketed
by profit-maximizing
corporations
is kind of worrisome from
a social point-of-view.
So we've started a benefit
corporation, wholly owned
by MAPS, no investors.
And it's not to
maximize profits.
It's to maximize social
change and social benefit.
And so that's what
we're showing here.
Now, you need to evaluate
the benefit corporation
to public benefit.
How do you tell that
you're really having
this benefit corporation?
And there are no third-party
standards, unfortunately,
for the pharmaceutical industry.
So we're creating our own
with some ethicists at UPenn.
And the challenge now is to
quantify the various principles
that we're operating under.
So we're working
on that right now.
There's a few more
things that we're doing.
We're also working on
MDMA-assisted psychotherapy
for autistic adults
with social anxiety.
And this is a study at UCLA.
It's a small pilot
study with 12 subjects.
We just have data
right now from eight.
But as you can see, this is the
Liebowitz Social Anxiety Scale.
It's working great.
And this is something that, in
a sense, Google helped develop.
Its crowd-sourced
drug development.
What that means is that somebody
who had autism went to a rave,
took Ecstasy, and said, wow.
Now, I can feel.
Now, I can read body language.
And they posted their
story on the internet.
And then, before long,
other people said, oh yeah,
that happened to me too.
And then, there was
about 50 or 100 accounts,
stories on the internet
of people with autism
saying MDMA helped them.
And so, a woman--
Alicia Danforth--
contacted as many as she could.
And her PhD dissertation
was talking to these people
through this sort of
crowd-sourced drug development
idea.
And then, we used that
as data to the FDA.
And so, this is really
encouraging data.
We're also doing a study with
life threatening illness,
people who have life
threatening illness that
are scared of dying.
And there was research with LSD.
There is research
with psilocybin.
And our research with MDMA
is now at San Anselmo.
This is Dr. Phil Wolfson.
It's a double-blind
study, 18 participants.
We've already enrolled five.
This was a front-page "San
Francisco Chronicle" article
about it.
And this is a study
that just happened.
We just got approval
for this on Tuesday.
This is the first
study in association
informally with VA therapists.
And when the VA was think-- as I
said, the Department of Defense
wasn't so excited about us doing
work with active-duty soldiers.
But the VA, they were thinking,
well, where do we blend MDMA?
And they had a program that
was called Cognitive Behavioral
Conjoint Therapy,
where "conjoint" means
couples therapy.
And they thought, OK, MDMA--
hug drug, love drug, couples.
Let's work it there.
So they introduced
us to the person
that was the VA therapist
who was working with this.
And we've decided to blend.
We're going to pay for the study
as a sort of prime the pump
with the VA.
But what we wanted to do was
give both members of the couple
MDMA.
And on Tuesday,
the FDA said yes.
And this is the first
instance that this modern wave
of psychedelic research-- it
began in 1990 with the DMT
research.
And it's always been
single patients.
So now, we have a chance to
actually give two people--
and that will hopefully help
us move, eventually, also
to look at group psychotherapy.
Now, we're also doing
work with marijuana.
I just want to say
that right now it's
more difficult to do
research with marijuana
than psychedelics.
The reason is that we have our
own supplies of psychedelics.
But there is
marijuana everywhere.
But the only
DEA-licensed marijuana
is owned by the National
Institute on Drug
Abuse, the agency that's
about what's bad with drugs.
And if you want to look at
what's good with marijuana,
they don't really want
to give it to you.
So we have tried for six years.
And we finally have been
able to get permission
for a study of marijuana
for PTSD in 76 US veterans.
Marijuana is a
palliative treatment.
It helps people not
have nightmares.
It helps them be
present, focused.
But it doesn't
solve the problem.
People need to take
marijuana every day.
But it still is helpful
for some people.
And so, we're sort of
becoming the experts in PTSD,
as well as experts in MDMA.
And so, Sanjay Gupta did a
series of stories on marijuana.
We were a big focus of
"Weed 3," our project.
Basically, this is
just to show that we're
comparing some
groups that get THC,
some groups that get CBD
containing marijuana,
and one group that gets
both, and then one that
gets a placebo.
And we got a $2.1 million grant
from the state of Colorado
for this study.
The state of Colorado has
taken in over $100 million
in taxes for marijuana.
And they put out $9 million
for marijuana research.
And they were willing
to give us $2.1 million.
This is a protest.
We're also suing the DEA.
Covington & Burling
is a big DC law firm.
They've agreed to take
the case pro bono.
We're trying to
break the monopoly.
And this is a
protest that we had
on the lawn of the
DEA headquarters
saying, give us a
license to grow pot.
Basically, it's the same
with the MDMA story.
We won the administrative
law judge lawsuit.
But then, the head of the DEA
rejected the recommendation.
So we're continuing to try.
And now, we get to Burning Man.
What are the potential
reasons for backlash
that would block our progress?
And it used to be, the
initial backlash in the '60s
was about political reasons,
about these hippies,
the counterculture, the Beatles
doing LSD, against the war,
make love not war.
The backlash was political.
But that has faded now.
And so now, the main
reason of backlash
would be parents worried
about their kids.
And an example is,
at Burning Man,
at festivals where
people do lots
of psychedelics, a bunch of
people are not prepared for it.
And what happens is they end
up either getting tranquilized
or getting arrested.
And so, we've started
the Zendo Project
to do psychedelic
harm-reduction at festivals
all over the world.
And we've picked some of the
more well-known ones, Burning
Man, Boom Festival in Portugal,
Envision in Costa Rica.
And we provide psychedelic
therapists and psychologists,
psychiatrists, to
help people, as a way
of trying to reduce the
costs and reduce the fears.
This is complicated
by the fact that there
is a law against harm
reduction with psychedelics.
It's called the RAVE
Act, Reducing America's
Vulnerability to Ecstasy.
You can't have too much
Ecstasy in America.
So it's a problem.
But we're working
politically to get that over.
This is our training
group at Burning Man.
We had 180 people
wanted to get training
in how to help people go
through a difficult trip.
To locate where we
were-- so the Burning
Man Organization is worried.
But they let people do
stuff-- all sorts of stuff
obviously-- in their villages.
So we do this in our villages.
We're not formally connected.
But we're getting more and
more connected informally.
And so we had to put
a flag up for people
to recognize where we were.
And so to have our own
Zendo flag at Burning Man,
it felt like I was an
explorer, planting my flag,
like we had our
own little country.
I felt so accepted to have
our little Zendo flag there.
And this is to show
you what's possible.
This just took place-- Burning
Man on the Washington DC Mall.
This took place in November.
We aligned ourselves with the
local Burning Man community.
And we actually-- you can't
just have a party on the Mall.
You have to be upset
about something.
[LAUGHTER]
You have to protest something.
So this, we timed it for the
Drug Policy Alliance Conference
in Washington, DC.
So this is a protest
against the drug war.
We actually did though have DJs.
We had dancing all night.
We had the Zendo team there.
This was right between the
White House and the Washington
Monument.
And the most exhilarating
moment for me
was around 4:30 in the morning,
dancing with David Bronner.
It was like we
thought, we did it.
We got the permits.
Everything's working.
There's over 1,000
people at the burn.
And at that moment, the
DJ put on Jimi Hendrix
playing the national
anthem from Woodstock,
and playing it so loud
that you could hear
the music in the White House.
And we thought, wow, here's
from counterculture Woodstock.
Now, we're doing Burning Man
with a permit, completely
legally, on the Washington Mall.
And the little
temple structure that
burned, once it burned down, it
burned to reveal a jail cell.
And then, the jail
cell burned down too.
And so, now, this
is our 30th year.
In April is our
30th anniversary.
We're asking people
to have dinners.
We're looking at, what
happened with gay marriage?
How did that work?
What happened with gay rights?
People came out.
People didn't they
knew gay people.
People, the same
thing, don't know
they know people who
have done psychedelics.
So we're asking
people to have dinners
in home private settings
and invite their friends
and just tell stories
about what psychedelics
have meant to them.
So some of you may be
interested in considering that.
And then, we're
asking at the end,
for people-- if they
want to donate--
to help us have
a legal drug deal
and contribute to our
$400,000 cost for the MDMA.
And we're also having a
conference in Oakland in 2017.
It's the third
iteration of this.
We're having
psychedelic researchers
from all over the world,
psychedelic science.
You're all welcome
to come to it.
And this is the final slide.
This is what I want
to leave you with.
In 2010, I got a call
from the Pentagon.
And it was from a
brigadier general.
She was the highest-ranking
psychiatrist in the military.
She was in charge
of PTSD research.
And she heard about
our study with MDMA.
And she called and
said, what's going on?
We have a terrible
problem with PTSD.
And so we have since shared
information with her.
And she's been
willing to go public.
She's now no longer in the DEA.
But she works here in
New York for the mayor.
And she said this.
"When it comes
to the health and
well-being of those
who serve, we should leave
our politics at the door
and not be afraid
to follow the data.
There is now an evidence
base for this MDMA therapy
and a plausible story about what
may be going on in the brain
to account for the effects."
So you can see that
our society is really--
I think-- opening
up to psychedelics.
We have a chance to
integrate medically and then
broaden, hopefully,
into more legalization
and then, hopefully, have
millions and tens of millions,
hundreds of millions
of people have
these spiritual experiences.
And before you know it, world
peace and the Google Department
of World Peace will
hopefully participate
in some way or another.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
OK, so any questions?
Julie, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Dr. Doblin, thank you
for mentioning this openness
issue with psilocybin that Dr.
McLean showed and that openness
being important for
changing behavior.
But this is the first I've
heard about openness being
measured in MDMA protocol.
So I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit more
about that.
RICK DOBLIN: Yeah.
Well, the psilocybin research
and the MDMA research,
we learned from each other.
So we saw that there was
a benefit in openness.
So we started using
the NEO in our studies.
And it's been a
long time, trying
to get the papers written.
But we now are using
the same personality
measures that were used there.
And we're getting
really good results
in both the Boulder study and
also in the Charleston study
with veterans.
So it's a good collaboration.
So the psychedelic researchers
are really not competing.
There sort of is a
competition in my mind, who
gets their drug approved first.
But we're trying
to help each other.
AUDIENCE: Healthy competition.
RICK DOBLIN: A healthy
competition, yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We've all
heard songs about popping
Molly in the club.
So do you think that
hedonistic attitudes
about how MDMA is like the
perfect way to spend the night
can coexist peacefully with
therapeutic mindsets about--
RICK DOBLIN: Yes, I do actually.
So I think that the problem
with hedonistic approaches
is that people are
really looking only
for the good experiences.
And they're missing
out on the fact
that difficult
experiences are ones where
people can grow from as well.
And that's a danger.
And so we've talked to
different people who
have said that they took MDMA
in recreational settings,
and then past trauma came up.
And within one week, we
had two different women
talk to us about this.
And one woman said,
I was with friends.
And they were sympathetic.
And we went off into a corner.
And I talked about
what happened.
I worked through it.
And then I was able to feel
better and go back to a party.
And another woman said, I
was with a bunch of people.
We were all going to have fun.
And I thought I would take
everybody down by telling them
about the serious stuff.
So I tried to stuff my feelings.
And now, it's weeks later
and I'm feeling worse.
So I think there's problems with
this, quote, "hedonistic use."
But I would say that
the celebratory use--
like is a lot of Burning
Man and other things--
that that can be very
healing and very spiritual.
So I think we tend to
denigrate recreational use.
It's somehow lower.
But I think that it's
people's attitudes.
When you open up
your mind, and if you
say I only want a
good part, I only
want the happy spectrum
of what's going on,
you're setting yourself
up for disaster.
And I think that a lot
of the young people that
use it hedonistically, it's
they don't know any different.
They don't know that
it's a therapeutic drug.
They only know of
it as a party drug.
So I think, as we develop
the therapeutic use
and as psychedelic
clinics set up,
people will be able to have a
deeper understanding of what
these drugs really do.
And also, as the rules
about harm reduction change,
hopefully we'll have
people at big festivals,
at even big clubs-- I mean,
they already have medical staff.
And if you could
have somebody that's
trained to help people if they
have a difficult experience,
then I think we'll have a lot.
But I do think that,
culturally, we're
past the point where tragedies
from the hedonistic use
will doom the medical use.
That was a big thing.
And I think now, the data
about the medical use
is so compelling and the need
is so great that, now, I'm
not worried about it.
But I do think we need to
redefine recreational use
and not just think
of it as totally
negative and hedonistic
and casual and reckless.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can you--
RICK DOBLIN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much for
coming and speaking to us.
And I have a question
in a similar vein,
where the data definitely
speaks for itself.
And it makes total
sense that there's
good medical use and really
[INAUDIBLE] to work out.
But at some point, politically,
some aspiring politician
may think, oh, this is
something that I can just
go after and say,
hey, drugs are bad.
It's terrible.
And this is what's
going to get me elected.
So what do you really
think is that critical mass
that we have to reach
to really be able to be
that this is mainstream?
And it won't be politically
savvy to say, no, MDMA,
LSD, psilocybin is terrible.
And you guys should keep
your kids away from it.
And you shouldn't be doing this.
RICK DOBLIN: Yes,
that's a great question.
And there are people like
that saying that now.
But there are less and less.
I think the critical
turning point
is going to be when FDA says yes
to making these into medicines.
And that'll be six years.
So I think it's perilous,
you could say, between now
and then.
Another turning point
is going to be sooner.
In this coming year, when
we negotiate with FDA
and the Heffter people
negotiate about psilocybin
and move to Phase
3-- once they say,
yes, you can go to Phase 3,
that's a strong endorsement.
And then, I think it will
not be possible to block
what we're doing, at least
until it gets to the point
where we have the data.
And then, the question is,
does it become approved?
But I think this idea
of politicians saying,
let's ramp up the
drug war-- that there
is rare bipartisan
anything in Washington.
But there is a fair amount
of bipartisan recognition
that mass incarceration has
been a disaster for America
and has been incredibly
racist, incredibly destructive.
And you know, the
Chinese say, crisis
is danger and opportunity.
So right now, the fact
that heroin and phentynol
are now used by more
and more white people
and there is more
and more deaths
from opiate addiction, that is
changing people's attitudes.
And now, there is a more
compassionate approach,
in a lot of places,
towards treatment
instead of incarceration.
So I think those
voices that are saying,
ramp up the drug
war-- they don't
have as much power anymore.
But I am sensitive to
the potential backlash.
But I feel fairly hopeful that
we will be able to continue.
But it is still risky.
And the other part of
it is the veterans.
So when you talk about
healing people that
are held in high
esteem by our culture--
I'm not trying to say I'm
pro-war and everything
the military does is great.
But by healing
veterans-- veterans
are a counter-force to
the police, to the DEA.
And in fact, in our study, we've
said, for political reasons,
we're going to change
the title of the study.
It's going to be
Veterans, Firefighters,
and Police Officers.
[LAUGHTER]
We didn't think we'd get
any firefighters or police
officers.
But of the 26 people,
we've got 22 veterans,
three firefighters-- including
one who was here at 9/11.
And we had one police
officer volunteer.
And so, when you think
about it, there's
very few jobs in America that
are as traumatizing as being
a police officer.
And because of
the drug war, I've
not had much compassion
for the police.
I felt like, I'm the prey
and they're the hunter.
But to try to get out
of that kind of mindset,
I think showing to the police
even that MDMA therapy can
help them in their
own-- there is just
a lot of terrible situations
that police have to see.
So we're doing what
we can to cross
those divides and
undercut arguments
that we need to protect the kids
or we need to protect America
by ramping up the drug war.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
wondering, how broad
is the term "psychedelic"?
In the sense of, what are
some of the differences
in the mechanisms and effects
when you talk about LSD
or psilocybin or MDMA?
RICK DOBLIN: Yeah,
great question.
So I would say that
there is a group of drugs
that we call the
classic psychedelics.
And those are like LSD,
mescaline from peyote,
mushrooms, ayahuasca, ibogaine.
And there's been
incredible research
now with brain scans with
people under the influence
of psychedelics.
So we have not just
psychedelic psychotherapy,
but psychedelic
neuroscience is happening.
And so there's two
different things
that happen with the
classic psychedelics
and then what's happened with
MDMA and drugs like that.
And the difference is that,
with the classic psychedelics,
there's a network in the
brain called the Default Mode
Network.
And that's more
or less identified
as the ego structures.
So it's like, when you're not
doing anything in particular,
you're kind of scanning
the environment,
you're looking for
what's important to you
for your different
hierarchy of needs,
but you're kind of ego-focused,
centered in yourself.
And there's actually
so much information
that we're perceiving
all the time,
but we don't pay
attention to it all.
It would be overwhelming.
So the Default Mode Network
filters out everything
that you think is not important.
Like there's noises of
the air conditioning.
There's noises that we're not
really paying attention to.
So what the classic
psychedelics do
is they weaken the
Default Mode Network.
And they permit a flood
of perceptions to emerge.
The woman, Amanda Fielding--
she heads the Beckley
Foundation in England.
She funded this research.
And what I'm so
proud of her for is
that she thought, since the
'60s, from her experiences
with LSD, that LSD must increase
blood flow in the brain.
It must increase your activity.
But actually it doesn't.
It decreases activity in
these Default Mode Networks.
MDMA doesn't really do that.
What MDMA does is
it reduces activity
in the amygdala, which
is the fear processing
part of the brain.
And it enhances activity in
the frontal cortex, where
you put things in associations.
So you have a reduced
fear about trauma.
And then, when you're
able to recall the memory,
you can really set
it in to the past
instead of constantly
intruding on the present.
And MDMA doesn't
dissolve the ego the way
the classic psychedelics do.
But it helps people feel
so grounded and centered
in themself that, then, they
can see the wider world.
Stan Groff has talked
about it as, you're
transparent to the transcendent.
And that's more like MDMA.
You become transparent
to the transcendent.
Whereas LSD sort of
dissolves everything that
keeps you feeling separate.
Yeah.
Great.
Any questions?
OK, I guess that's it.
OK, thank you very much.
It was great.
[APPLAUSE]